we tend to believe that when there's  a change that's introduced to our life  either wanted or unwanted that  it happens in a vacuum it happens in  this isolated way where I am Maya the  exact same person almost walking through  a magic mirror but with that one little  change that one tweak made in my life  and that's just not how human beings  work where these really rich complex  ecosystems where change in one part of  our Lives naturally has lots of  spillover effects into other parts of  our lives and I think the lesson I've  learned from that is we need to be we  need to approach change with a profound  amount of humility  because we simply can't anticipate all  of the ways in which the change will  affect us